what is up guys my name is Jana and
welcome back welcome back to Java 3d
Java game development okay yes so I
haven't done anything obviously since we
left off him probably gonna stop saying
that at the start of every video but
yeah there are a few things I want to
talk about today and I promise last time
we would get to rendering pixels and
stuff to the screen but that's not gonna
happen today just because I actually
have to explain a bunch of stuff today's
today's today and today we're basically
gonna talk about arrays because they are
very very important okay first thing
real quick is I want to add two things
to our running and that is tick and
render real quick tick is going to
basically handle like the time and like
the frames per second like that sort of
stuff and the rent well not really but
stuff to do with timing and the rent is
obviously gonna deal with rendering
things to the screen and we'll have to
create methods real quick and I'll type
it up type it out just for you guys
so public void I could probably go
private actually private void tick
and private void render and we're gonna
touch that for now
but the thing we're going to do now is
we're gonna create a new class so you
can right click here go new class and
we're gonna call it render I'm just
gonna call render for now and we're
gonna put it into a subfolder in mine
front called graphics because graphics
is going to basically contain all the
stuff that's going to actually render
software screen and this is sort of
going to be our main rendering class hit
finish okay so for this I want to put a
few things actually let's go back into
displayed a Java real quick and actually
make it private render render
okay and you know I have two important a
different folder so it's in a different
package okay so we're going to create
three integers yeah yeah three three is
fun we're gonna make them public so that
we can see them inside our display Oh
Java class and this is where it's gonna
get a bit interesting after in we're
gonna put square brackets open and
closing and pixels okay I'll explain
this in a minute actually I should I do
this first okay I'll make the
constructor first okay and this is going
to have obviously we need to do this
this is just standard Java thing and
pixels equals int width times height
okay let's talk about this code real
quick actually not real quick because
this is pretty much all we're gonna do
today
because I really want to explain this
properly so basically what we're doing
is we're creating on I will do that
later it looks plain at first what we're
doing is we're creating three three
variables we're recommending the width
which will actually inherit
okay I thought we made a method last
time almost out of constructor sorry
public display and screen goes new
screen and with height
okay screen render screens something
completely different which will do it
and I won't know why I'm doing that
right now okay yeah okay let's talk
about this first they don't get on to
that with is going to be sort of
inherited by this it's pretty hard to
explain okay let's talk about this
constructor I'll talk about this a
minute we're basically made a
constructor with two parameters width
and height with this top width equals
width we're saying that this width this
would is equal to this width and this
width with with with this width is comes
from here okay and this width is equal
to 800 so effectively where well
effectively we're saying that we're
initializing an integer of 800 here but
we have to set it up this way so that we
can use it in this class and in this in
this way which will in this way you know
in an array which we'll talk about in
about five seconds has it been five
seconds I think so okay so these square
brackets are indicating that are
indicating that this integer is going to
be an array and what an array is is it's
an it's built like this by the way
you've probably heard of it before if
you've done programming what an array is
is it's a bunch of sort of it's a bunch
of variables of the same type so I
thought long and hard that's what she
said I thought long and hard about how
to UM how to explain this and I think
that the best way to do it is this first
of all pixels are literally pixels on
the screen we've just created that name
just so that it's it's easy if you guys
want to stand and out of the pixels
we're creating the array so we're create
a large number of variables and the
number of variables we're creating is
width times height which is 800 x 600
which is 8 times 6 is 48 about 480,000
I'll just check that 400 what am i doing
800 x 600 yeah four hundred and eighty
thousand my maths perfect you have to be
good at maths if you want to be a
programmer that's for sure
I'm not actually a programmer but this
is more like a hobby of me anyway so
wait we have to create so basically what
this is doing is creating four hundred
and eighty thousand variables and the
best way to think of this is income
paint net if we go if we generally grid
and we'll make this really small
I guess that's quite small each one of
these oh okay let me just back up real
quick
maybe five or something okay think of
this each one of these is a pixel on our
screen alright and we need wool we
obviously need 800 by 600 pixels because
that's the value so I've got two motors
here I could record both of them somehow
but it's not gonna happen we have chosen
for our window size at the moment to be
800 by 600 so we want to render an area
of 800 by 600 in order in order to do
that especially without like from
scratch from scratch what you need to do
is you need to pretty much initialize
each one of those pixels so each one of
those 480 thousand pixels at the moment
if we increase this resolution that
numbers gonna go up quite a bit so
basically what this is creating is is
this it's assigning the array the array
like the okay it's assigning 480,000
variables to an array which is assigned
to this variable called pixels so pixels
is taking on 480,000 variables that's
yeah that's that's quite a bit so
basically the way that Java does this is
if
I open up notepad is it assigns a number
it assigns them from numbers 0 to 399
sorry 3 what is it 480 thousand six
hundred seventy 9999 and that's going to
equal obviously 480 thousand total
variables total numbers so I guess the
best way to think of this if you feel
like if you're really basic in Java is
instead of us going public fire okay
instead of us just going into job say
pixel 1 equals I don't know 1 and doing
this basically 480 thousand times but of
course changing this changing the name
instead of us doing that we can just
sort of make one variable one line of
code and that'll handle all of that and
the other thing is if we decide to
increase it well I guess it you you
could definitely see that it does not
there's not much explaining to do here
you can definitely see why we need to
raise and why we use them and yeah so
that's that's a raise next time we will
hopefully move on to actually drawing
pixels on the screen I'm not sure how
much code that will take I haven't
written it yet
we'll do that we'll do that alive next
time screw it we'll do it live so yeah
I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]